Élémentaire mon cher Watson.
Salut, aujourd'hui :
Pour l'avant dernière vidéo de l'année,
je vous propose deux énigmes à la Sherlock Holmes.
J'ai une voix un petit peu bizarre,
parce que je suis de plus en plus malade,
et je suis en train de perdre ma voix !
Le Mental Vlog aura eu raison
de ma santé.
Trois choses rapides avant de lancer
les deux énigmes :
Première chose, n'oubliez pas de me suivre
sur les réseaux sociaux
si vous voulez participer aux
prochaines vidéos,
parce que je suis en train de préparer
des choses avec vous.
Vous avez les liens dans la description.
Deuxième chose, si vous êtes abonnés,
n'oubliez pas de cliquer sur la cloche
pour être notifiés des prochaines vidéos
puisque je ne sais pas encore précisément
quand est-ce que vont sortir
les premières vidéos de janvier,
que vous ne les ratiez pas.
Et troisième chose :
Demain c'est la dernière vidéo du défi
"Une vidéo par jour pendant 1 an"
du Mental Vlog.
Défi qu'on est sur le point de réussir,
je crois...
J'avais pris deux engagements
au cours de l'année
en répondant à diverses blagues ;
Comme quoi j'allais expliquer
comment devenir invisible
dans la dernière vidéo.
Ce que je vais faire.
Et on m'avait mis au challenge,
au mois de février,
de me mettre à nu dans
la dernière vidéo,
si je passais les 100.000 abonnés.
Donc, euh, demain...
Donc demain, quoi !
Bon, bref :
les énigmes.
[Musique Générique]
Enfilez votre casquette de Sherlock Holmes,
prenez votre plus belle pipe
et résolvez ces énigmes.
La première énigme c'est que
la sœur du Docteur Watson
a deux enfants
et l'un des deux enfants
est un garçon.
Je vous pose la question,
chers détectives,
quelle est la probabilité,
je parle bien de la probabilité,
que le deuxième enfant soit une fille.
Vous pouvez me répondre en fraction
ou vous pouvez aussi me répondre
en pourcentage.
Si vous êtes sûr et certain de la réponse
ne la mettez pas dans
les commentaires,
Puisque je vais donner les réponses
à la fin de la vidéo
faudrait pas spoiler les autres.
Par contre mettez :
SHERLOCK
Vous mettez juste SHERLOCK
dans les commentaires.
Mais peut-être arriverez-vous mieux
ou moins bien
à résoudre la deuxième énigme...
[Cliquetis du compteur]
Ça, ça veut dire qu'il y a des gens
qui viennent de s'abonner.
Salut, les nouveaux gens !
C'est un petit gadget de noël
que je me suis offert.
Il n'y a pas de placement de produit,
c'est avec mes sous,
mais ça me fait bien rigoler.
La deuxième énigme est beaucoup
plus triste
puisque nous allons devoir résoudre,
ensemble,
ce qui a tout l'air d'être un suicide.
Plongez vous dans l'époque de
Sherlock Holmes
ça vous permettra d'avoir le décor,
d'avoir plus d'informations peut-être
pour résoudre cette énigme.
En tout cas, il s'agit d'une jeune femme
qui s'appelle Latnem.
Latnem a 32 ans, elle est mariée,
elle n'a pas encore d'enfant
et elle a été retrouvée morte dans sa chambre.
C'est pas très gai, hein ?
Dans la chambre il y avait
une cheminée à gaz
qui était reliée au chauffage central.
C'était très courant à cette époque.
Et alors, que ce soit bien clair :
le gaz était branché mais n'était pas allumé.
Pourtant, apparemment,
c'est le gaz qui est à l'origine de la mort.
Il y aura une autopsie de faite
qui permettra sûrement de confirmer ça,
mais on en est quasiment certain.
Alors le truc c'est que la mère de Latnem
nous a précisé que c'était impossible
que sa fille se suicide.
Elle n'était pas suicidaire.
Elle avait un super moral,
une belle joie de vivre.
Alors que la police, elle, pense que
c'est un suicide.
Bons Sherlocksiens que vous êtes,
vous allez peut-être trouver
une autre piste.
Surtout que je vais vous donner
quand même quelques précisions,
mais il n'y avait pas un papier,
vous savez, un petit papier,
un petit mot
que, malheureusement, beaucoup
laissent quand ils mettent fin à leurs jours.
Ça c'est très étonnant.
Et les fenêtres de la chambres !
Après un petit examen minutieux,
que j'ai fait pour vous !
Les fenêtres de la chambre étaient
fermées de l'intérieur
et hermétiquement closes.
Elles étaient parfaitement intactes.
Elles n'ont pas été forcées,
il n'y avait rien de louche dessus.
Comme la porte d'ailleurs !
J'ai bien regardé la porte :
Elle était fermée à clef
et de l'intérieur en plus.
On a été obligé de la défoncer
pour l'ouvrir.
Donc ça veut dire que Latnem
était toute seule dans cette chambre,
mais pourtant ce ne serait pas un suicide.
Moi je vais vous le dire,
je sais que c'est un meurtre.
Je sais même quelle est la personne coupable.
Et je sais même quel est son mode opératoire.
Comment la personne a tué Latnem.
Et vous ?
Est-ce que vous avez trouvé ?
C'est ça la vraie question.
Si vous avez trouvé,
dans les commentaires, ne le dites pas
encore une fois
laissez le suspens un peu,
ne spoilez pas les nouveaux.
Mais vous pouvez mettre "HOLMES"
Juste comme ça,
en petit commentaire.
Donc si vous avez trouvé les deux,
vous mettez SHERLOCK HOLMES
Si vous n'en avez trouvé qu'un
vous mettez SHERLOCK
si vous n'avez trouvé que le deuxième,
vous mettez HOLMES.
Et alors maintenant,
nous allons passer aux réponses.
Donc si vous ne voulez pas avoir
la réponse tout de suite,
vous quittez ici la vidéo
et vous reviendrez plus tard,
quand vous voudrez vérifier
votre réponse.
Et sinon, attention !
Je vais la donner dans quelques secondes.
Attention c'est parti pour les réponses !
Première énigme :
Quelle est la probabilité que la sœur
du Docteur Watson
ait une fille comme deuxième enfant ?
En fraction c'est 2/3 et donc
en pourcentage c'est à peu près 67%
Et là je vous entends, derrière l'écran
dire : "Mais non, c'est une chance
sur deux, en fait,
c'est 50% de chance."
Non, c'est bien 2 sur 3.
En fait, en probabilités,
il faut prendre toutes les possibilités.
Donc, en possibilités d'enfants
qu'elle ait pu avoir,
ça aurait pu faire :
1 garçon et 1 garçon,
ou 1 fille et 1 garçon
ou 1 garçon et 1 fille
ou 1 fille et 1 fille.
1 fille et 1 fille
on l'élimine d'entrée
parce qu'on sait déjà qu'elle
a un garçon sur les deux.
Il reste donc :
Garçon - Garçon
Garçon - Fille
ou Fille - Garçon
Et dans ces 3 possibilités,
il y a 2 possibilités où
il y a Fille.
C'est donc bien 2 chances
sur 3 possibilités.
C'est ça les proba...
Et si jamais vous étiez tombés
dans le piège
de 1 chance sur 2,
de 50%
vous pouvez me mettre une insulte...
... gentille
dans les commentaires.
Une gentille...
Faut pas exagérer non plus !
Réponse de la deuxième énigme :
Alors, oui c'est le mari qui a
assassiné sa femme.
Alors malheureusement c'est pas très sympa
mais c'est comme ça.
Donc, notre chère Latnem est allée se coucher.
Avant de se coucher, elle a allumé
sa cheminée au gaz.
Une fois que Latnem s'est endormie,
son mari a coupé le gaz
au niveau de l'arrivée centrale.
C'est à dire qu'il n'avait pas besoin
de pénétrer dans la chambre.
Il a coupé le gaz,
donc ça a éteint la cheminée.
Donc : plus de flammes...
Donc le feu s'est éteint.
Et c'est là où ça devient intéressant :
Une fois que le feu s'est éteint,
le mari a rallumé le gaz
au niveau de l'arrivée centrale.
Donc le gaz s'est propagé dans la pièce,
[bruits à l'extérieur du bureau]
un peu comme le bruit que ferait un camion pubelles
juste devant ma fenêtre pendant que je filme...
Le gaz s'est propagé dans toute la pièce
et a asphyxié cette pauvre Latnem,
sans que le mari n'ait à pénétrer dans la chambre.
En même temps il a essayé de faire
le meurtre parfait.
Mais nous l'avons démasqué !
D'ailleurs il y a une troisième énigme
dans cette énigme.
Euh... je ne vais pas vous la dire.
Ce n'est pas vraiment une énigme,
mais il y a un petit truc particulier
dans cette énigme.
Un petit clin d’œil dirons nous.
Si vous l'avez trouvé, vous pouvez me le dire.
Ça en fait des choses à se dire aujourd'hui.
Comme d'habitude,
si cette vidéo vous a plu,
vous pouvez la liker
ou vous abonner
et rendez-vous demain
à 11 h
ouais, ouais, ouais, ouais, ouais,
ouais, ouais, ouais, ouais
CIAO !
[Musique générique fin]